[Music]
gladiator the character druva
what a journey what an experience and uh
it was fun and at the same time it was a
bit confusing because this was my uh
second film
right after i missed that and uh going
into it i
high hopes and
big expectations i guess part of it left
me a little bit perplexed because we had
so many it would seem like we have
a lot of conflict in um bringing the
story together and needless to say uh
riley scott was a master at keeping
things cool and uh and he would just
every night in a corner just uh
working and
continuously working on the story and
trying to better the story in the
storyline of gladiator the the
experience was just overwhelming given
the fact that we were it would seem like
we were filming two different um
stories at the same time
you had the gladiator world that we were
filming and where
i was mostly present and then you had
the uh
the woman kingdom
and that i mean it was just too
different world it would seem yeah you
know you could only get one so the film
was finished do you believe you'll see
them again when you die
i think so
but then
i will die soon
they will not die for many years
i'll have to wait
some other you know nice scenes that we
did uh my last uh
shot was pretty much the last shot of
the film
as you see me bury the ancestors of uh
maximus
i mean or his relatives that was the
last scene that i did before leaving
the set and that scene was as i
understood the studio
well the majority of the production was
not aware of what we were making what we
were doing actually particularly in
regards to the scene because that scene
was not written
you see it was not written we didn't
know how we're going to finish the film
because obviously you know you know
towards the end of filming we had lost
uh one important character in the making
of gladiator
and that was uh oliver reed
and so that shifted everything and
changed everything and so
how do we end the film was
uh
i'm sure was in uh in discussion
studio and obviously ridley so how we
shot that last scene was just a surprise
to everybody and no one was around it
was the end of the day with just one
camera operator
the director and myself and
it was beautiful i will see you again
but not yet
not yet
1997 the character of sinking that
film had to be
life-changing
for multiple reasons because i had moved
from
france
to california with the idea of pursuing
acting and um it would have you know it
would seem like a far-fetched dream
since uh i did at the time i didn't
speak english so that was quite uh
life-changing
my first lead role and being directed by
steven spielberg was absolutely
overwhelming and i learned so much
in making a mistake i learned
that
often time when directors don't talk to
you
you're in uh on the good highway if you
will of your performance you're on a
good highway
if you start getting too much uh i i
mean that was sort of like my take on it
we won't be going in there alone
alone indeed not now we have right at
our side we have righteousness at our
side
we have mr baldwin over there
working with anthony hopkins and morgan
freeman obviously
my second day of filming i was oh i
think it was the first i was working
with morgan freeman and the scene was
very emotional but i would seem like i
had a void
in the performance
and so i uh asked morgan freeman was
like does it happen sometimes that you
you know you're not feeling it but
you're not you know
he said yeah that's uh it happens and
that doesn't mean that you're not doing
a good job
you just have to trust the moment to let
go
and um and be it and so that was uh
working with those uh
iconic um actors nowadays uh looking
back was absolutely elevating
blood diamond
solomon
thunder wow blood diamond was
in many ways an eye opener that was a
treacherous journey that film sort of
like
came with uh some inherent um a bit of
an obligation
to be part of that film even if i didn't
get paid
i mean i i would have done it not
getting paid but uh because
historically
economically
the plight of the continent you could uh
really a bit of that was the first time
you could really get a hint of the
unfair trade rules
between countries right
business
that particular scene in the prison that
was a difficult scene
i did not know and i did not know how
we're gonna
shoot that scene we just started rolling
and just trying to see how
it would all get organically come
together and um it was a one-take thing
maybe twice for the most
and that was it it was a great scene my
brothers
i got one thousand dollars to the man
who caused a diamond out that is
oh so much of uh making that film was
difficult so much of it was painful
emotionally painful
because so much knowledge was coming as
far as the
like i said the trade rules between
countries uh you know and also the
exportation of the countries in africa
there was rarely anything positive
coming out of the continent of africa so
this was an opportunity to really a
little bit to shine light on some of the
issues that really uh completely um
in a way that africa can't seem to
defend itself some of those countries
that have you know like the congo region
that has so much minerals they can't
seem to
manage their wealth you know there's a
definitely a stranglehold from the
developed countries also preying on
some of those uh countries who are full
of minerals so
i use just an amazing uh eye opener
making blood diamond now you listen here
my boy you listen well you are not going
down there are we clear you are not the
master
right now that is exactly what i am and
you better remember it kapha
working with the dicaprio and edward
sweet which is absolutely amazing now
what a journey also i mean it was just
uh
the capri myself for the most part we
were just
in nature
yeah we spent a long time in nature just
uh walking the fields of africa you know
oh it was just such an amazing journey
for the you know i mean for me
particularly
uh to be working with um such a young
talent and um so gifted uh and so
nonchalantly um embraces whatever comes
his way in a way that
some of us feels a little timid about it
than this
and but um
what a great guy great guy to work with
and to have as a friend to know as a
friend he's pretty amazing
guardians of the galaxy captain marvel
korath
we had a great song filming it uh it was
quite a bit of a struggle with the
costume right costumes were quite uh
painful any move you made
you know in action you're about to cut
yourself
with your costume it was a it's quite
painful to uh to the experience of
making that one i think we're coming to
understand certain things about action
and superheroes and their costumes and
um but it took now on days we
seems like uh they do costumes so much
uh
so much better
yeah i was uh excitedly thrilled
to uh to you know to to be part of that
film and uh to also play this uh i would
say never dying character
yeah it was quite nice to play a machine
a complete you know a character that's
completely driven by uh one purpose and
one purpose only
to uh you know hunt people down and uh
yeah i did like that what is your name
my name is peter quill okay dude chill
out
why
ronan may have questions for you
hey you know what there's another name
you might know me by
well it's a it's a world that you never
quite uh come to understand until
you see it on screen right until it's
it's it's finished because we are also a
little bit baffled as to when uh you
read the script the description of the
space you're in
all that seemed a little bit fine and
you know of course he's not part of this
world you know
so you're a little bit perplexed as to
what world and what uh you know
uh sort of like a sight to you and in
this particular scene
you know so you never really get uh this
scope of the your environment in
filming those uh green screen
it's only once you're done with it it's
quite gratifying when you see
uh it come all together with you know
the the part that you only saw that was
green before plus
all the actions and all that then
then you got something obviously
tangible to show but up until then we uh
we're just like uh an audience waiting
to really get an essence of
what that visual
is
the four figures my character she's abu
fatman that was like quite a you know it
felt like a spiritual experience his
spiritual journey in a way you know we
were gone to this uh absolutely isolated
place
in the middle of nowhere in morocco and
trying to bring this film together and
there was like a number of uh
windstorms that were happening regularly
we were losing tents and people would
get you know
getting hurt and
it was just a tough film to make the
journey itself felt spiritual because we
were just in the middle of nowhere and
it was just us
in the film and
so if it really strange experience
you laugh like an englishman
and how does an englishman laugh
that was uh quite a gratifying
experience uh working with heath ledger
uh it was uh wonderful to work with him
and he was just uh you know artistically
he was so
young and ripe if you were you could
feel there was so much talent in him
somebody who is obviously uh passionate
about the work as well
likes to have fun but we enjoy the work
and takes the work very seriously
it was wonderful working with him in
america
again a part of it uh
of in america was a bit spiritual i was
playing a character obviously that was
severely ill completely disconnected
from family members and
really
a man
quite alone
a sad living
i myself at the time was uh trying to uh
play this character was a little bit uh
emotionally
uh spiritually i had to also going on
diet for
months trying to sort of like break my
uh physicality down a little bit and
then in the mix of it to realize that
not everybody loses that much you know
once
uh you you have age and
not everybody gets skinny you know from
the illness necessarily so that was
quite troublesome and um i felt really
uh alone making a film and
every
aspect of it that seemed a little bit
sad i felt it i'm even in love with your
anger
i mean longer than anything that lives
you're doing it
how'd you train your dragon
drago
that was fun um that was my first
animated film it got to me to understand
a little bit about myself in terms of uh
performance uh going into it i didn't
not know you had to play
those visual characters very large you
know
larger than life in a way which is
slightly different than when you're
doing a
live-action film yeah so how to turn
your dragon was a great uh
learning experience
about to join voiceovers
and meet me at birth right you're not
you're by yourself you're
in your world which in a way it could be
uh quite um good
to be in your own world and creating it
but you have to be really
bigger than life uh in uh bringing some
of those characters alive
and you led them to me
my appeal to the film was uh first of
all it was
uh had two successful franchise it's
also directed by somebody i really
had a lot of admiration for and uh was
in the hopes of working with him one day
uh and that was matthew vaughn the
director
he's got a style and um perception of
vision that's
quite
unusual and
very creative very creative in his
approach of
in filming so when this came about it
was absolutely no brainer to join the
team an amazing ensemble cast yeah it
was exactly what i was hoping for
[Music]
i did a lot of my stunts but also this
was one of the
uh the first film that i was uh quite
happy to have i had an amazing
uh stump double
about the same height same body and he
was quite uh brilliant and so
there was this was the first time that i
really
enjoyed and let go the fact that i can't
do
and certain things that it's not
necessarily good for me to do but he was
able to uh to help bring in the uh the
the fight all the fight sequences that
you see and all that as much as i mean
it uh my stomp double was also halfway
in it and um
really it was a tremendous uh help that
and this was the first time i was like
really
keen on letting go and having somebody
else do a part of my
you know action